لم تجف بعد دماء شهداء مجزره مخيم ومدينه
جنين حتى كانت وحدات خاصه قد اختالت ثلاثه
مقاومين في بلده جبع جنوبي جنين وحده
مستعربين حصلت المقاومين في سياره ومن ثم
دفعت قوات الاحتلال بتعزيزات واطلقت وابلا
من النيران على الشبان الثلاثه ثم اخرجت
جثثهم من السياره وعمدت قوات الاحتلال الى
تفجيرها
نقلت الجثامين الى المستشفى في مدينه جنين
ومن هناك انطلقت جنازه الشهداء الذين
ينتمون لكتيبه جبع اتابعتي لسرايا القدس
ذراع المسلح لحركه الجهاد الاسلامي جنازه
توحدت فيها الرايات
المقاومه اليوم
ان يكون خير ساد عون هذه المقاومه
الفلسطينيين فدعوه الى الانتقام واستمرار
المقاومه اننا سنرد النار بالنار فالرصاص
جاهز والبنادق موجوده القياده والرئاسه
والفصائل على اختلاف اطيافها حملت
الاحتلال تداعيه ما وصفتها بالحرب
المفتوحه في الضفه الغربيه توجه ضربات
قاضيه بشكل يومي للجهود الامريكيه
والدوليه والاقليميه المبذوله لتحقيق
التهدئه
انجاح
التفاهمات مع الجانب الفلسطيني
[تصفيق]
وفي جنين موكب جنائزي اخر اتشيع الاهالي
فتن استشهد متاثرا بشراح التي اصيب بها
برصاص الاحتلال قبل يومين
وفي اقل من شهرين ونصف قتل الاحتلال اكثر
من ثمانيه وسبعين فلسطينيا فيما سجلت اكثر
من 2000 حاله اعتقال
عداد ارقام هكذا يصرف الفلسطينيون مواكب
تشييع الشهداء الذين يسقطون برصاص
الاحتلال في كل يوم وفي كل مره ففعال
الاصوات والدعوات لنبذ الخلافات وانهاء
الانقسام لمواجهه مشاريع القتل
الاسرائيليه بدل انتظار بياناتي
والاستنكار الجزيره
جنوب جنين